-It's kind of funny.
Like, the first year
that we met,
there was a really huge hit
that kind of took over
our little home-school
tutorial thing.
-Who is this?
-Do you know -- it's called
"Idiot Boyfriend."
Do you know that song?
[ Laughter ]
-My song?
-Yeah.
-My comedy song?
-"Idiot Boyfriend"?
-Huge hit with the --
with the Paramore crew.
-I was the influence
for Paramore?
-Yes!
[ Laughter ]
100%.
-100%?
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-My disc --
[ Both laugh ]
Really?
"Idiot Boyfriend"?
-Thousand percent.
The music video -- iconic.
-That was Zooey Desch--
-Yes!
-I had a disco comedy song...
-Mm-hmm.
-...when disco was at its peak.
[ Laughter ]
2000 -- 2003.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And --
-It was so good.
-No, it was not.
-Your falsetto.
-No. Where did you
even hear that song?
MTV.
-MTV! Yes.
-They're the only people
that would --
Thank you, MTV.
They were the only people
that ever played it, ever, once.
-Every morning,
getting ready for, like,
our home-school thing --
It wasn't even, like,
really a school,
but it was --
we met up to do something.
And every morning had MTV on,
and, like, your song
played more than, like --
I think John Mayer
had a song out at the same time.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, we have
similar careers.
-You got some spins, man.
You got --
-I got some spins in there.
Maybe we can go out
to commercial
doing one of
your earliest influences.
If you wouldn't mind...
[ Cheering ]
...singing with me.
-I would be honored.
♪♪
-♪ I know what you want ♪
♪ And I know what you need ♪
♪♪
♪ But I'm gonna screw it up ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm an idiot ♪
♪ And I'm your boyfriend ♪
♪ Yes, I am ♪
-♪ And I'm gon' take you out ♪
♪♪
♪ Leave my wallet home ♪
♪ Then I'll use
your cellphone, baby ♪
♪ Long distance ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm your boyfriend ♪
-Hayley Williams, everybody!
Come on!